southern border and they're doing it now
masterfully
do me because president biden rolled
back a lot of the orders of the previous
administration that were working
one of the perhaps most reprehensible
things i've heard in a long time
is nancy pelosi and summon
administration saying
that this is caused by uh pent-up demand
from the previous administration there's
always a pent-up demand for crime
crossing the border illegally is illegal
and so we shouldn't accommodate that
pent-up demand
they seem to be signaling that we should
and here's what's happening
uh there's no question this trip has
confirmed it for me there is indeed
disorder at the border by executive
order
no question about it we went first to uh
a detention facility
48 million dollars to build they're
spending tens of thousands of dollars a
day
just to feed this this surge they're
spending tens of thousand dollars more a
day
to clothe them to transfer them all this
money's taken being taken apart
away from the things we're doing here in
the country that could benefit our
citizens
it is so bad from a from a financial
standpoint for border patrol
that as kevin alluded to they're taking
money from
the future payments down the road later
in the year of
border patrol salaries and border patrol
pensions
just to try and pay for the surge that's
going on right now that was caused by
this president
and they're hoping for supplemental but
that supplemental doesn't come i don't
know how
we're going to pay these guys what are
we doing
right what are we doing another thing
they are uh
they are not testing these individuals
we saw hundreds of hundreds of people in
there today
not one of them had a covet and they're
transferring to other places
without covetess border patrol agents
are only been occupated at 50 to 60
at the most right now they're exposed
every day to this
and this is something that the president
has caused with this surge
so then we went over to uh monument
three
uh right around the the hill here and we
saw firsthand what was going on
and kevin alluded to what's going on
hundreds of people a day coming across
we saw gaps in the in the wall that made
no sense they were almost done and on
january 20th at midnight they're
instructed to stop
and now we have a vulnerabilities
because of that and they're exploiting
those vulnerabilities
and perhaps worse than that 120 agents
that guard that area that's now
vulnerable
are being pulled away to go deal with
the uh feed and clothe these kids coming
across
and by the way when kids come across if
you don't think the drug traffickers are
doing it
think again most men have a piece of
tape across their shirt with
instructions on who they are
where they're going and what information
they get and what they need to do
so that's very organized and they're
paying a lot of money per child to get
them across
right the last thing i'll tell you is
something that very much concerns me as
a homeland security
ranking member people they've caught in
the last few days
over there in sector three or monument
three have been under the terror
watchlist
individuals that they have on the watch
list for terrorism are now starting to
exploit the southern border we need to
wake up
we need to understand listen mr
president button you're an okay guy
why don't you just admit you made a
mistake with this policy and go back to
the way it was and keep america safe for
all of us
and and use that money that we're
wasting down here
on our american citizens the door should
not be open
and we should have immigration the right
way and with that i'd like to invite
my good friend tony gonzalez from
homeland security committee up here
tony's from texas
and he's going to talk to you more thank
you very much
today is about the men and women in
green
our border patrol agents are doing god's
work
keeping our borders safe and for that
i want them to know we have your back
i am grateful that you know leader
mccarthy and other members
of the congressional delegation made it
down today for too long
our border communities have been
forgotten
that has changed that is changing today
we have your back america
is a nation of immigrants we are also
a nation of laws
border security and legal immigration
go hand in hand we are compassionate
people
we do not want to see overcrowding in
our spaces
we do not want to see families make
dangerous treks
across countries that they don't
understand
and put themselves at risk what we want
to do
is we want to attract the best and the
brightest
that this world has to offer and we want
them to come
in a legal fashion and we can do that
but that first starts by supporting our
border security
border security and legal immigration go
hand in hand
thank you all for coming i'm i'd like to
now turn
it over to august fluger my neighbor to
the south
folks thank y'all for being here the
fact that the bible administration and
president biden himself
will not admit that this is a crisis is
a shame
even those in in his administration in
hhs
have admitted that we have a refugee
crisis they have set
several additional housing locations one
in my district 700 people were moved
overnight with no notification to local
elected people no notification to the
sheriff's or law enforcement or the
judges
overnight 700 unaccompanied people
unaccompanied children
have been moved into midland texas the
biden
administration and his policies have
resulted in some winners and losers the
winners
are the human traffickers who know that
because we don't have a secure border
that they can move these children and
when we looked in their eyes today
what we saw was children who were being
taken advantage of exploited on that 22
mile
22 day trip and not only that
but the fact that we have folks who are
on the terrorist watch list
that are being moved into this country
illegally
that are taking advantage of these bad
policies that know because we don't have
a strong
secure border that the border wall
construction has stopped and been halted
about 22 days ago now they have
something to take advantage of
we implore the biden administration to
come visit
to see what their policies have done to
these children
what they have done to make our country
less secure i'd like to introduce
congressman joyce from ohio
thank you all for being here and thank
you for the opportunity to review the
border situation
uh the interior department controls 40
of the border
and unfortunately the backlog that has
been created we've been
managing over the last few years to
knock down is now being exacerbated
because the things that were being done
on the wall when this was all stopped or
not being done anymore
what was important is that there's a 173
percent increase in the last month
of people coming across the border kids
coming across the border
it's humanitarian crisis it's a legal
crisis and it needs to be fixed and
addressed
some of the agents are just telling us
that as a member of the opioid
caucus i could tell you that with
fentanyl coming across this border
more kids are going to die we're killing
our own kids we're making it
unsafe for those kids who are making the
voyage up here and why because we don't
tell them that
we are a country of immigrants
but we are also a country of laws and
those two
don't have to contradict each other
thank you and i introduced my friend
chuck fleischman from the interior
good afternoon i'm chuck fleischman i am
the appropriator
uh chair of the appropriations
subcommittee
on on appropriations i want to speak
with you all today i'm sorry i'm the
ranking member
optimism i'm a little bit shaken today
i've made several trips to the border
mcallen
rio grande sector here in el paso with
the past administration
in regard to my capacity but today
we are seeing a crisis now a crisis
such as pandemic is large
it has immediate concerns it has
long-term concerns
but this crisis at the border
which was incentivized president biden
and his minions created an
environment causing the surge that's
what's wrong about this talk to the
migrants they've been told
come on come across from all over
a host of countries what does that mean
human costs humanitarian costs it means
complete failure here at the border it
means threats to the united states
my my counterparts have talked about a
lot of the different specifics
but let me be clear about this
what we need to do is no more euphemisms
from this white house
no more political maneuvering by pelosi
and schumer
to try to call it a challenge it is a
crisis
with dire multiple
problems involved with this what we need
to do is act now
act as americans act united and i will
close with this
as the appropriator on homeland security
we know they're going to come with what
a supplement a request for more money
we've got to put those resources where
they're needed but just think of it
but for the actions of this president
which he will not acknowledge
he's created this crisis we have got to
stop it we've got to come
together as americans not just
republicans and democrats
not just members of the administration
or the house and senate but as americans
and deal with us
thank you
my good friend clay higgins from
louisiana
thank you sir ladies and gentlemen thank
you for being here today
it's it's unfortunate that we
as a nation have allowed this crisis to
develop and it began
last year when then candidate
biden continuously messaged
that he was going to weaken law
enforcement
missions on the border stop construction
of the wall
and create a pathway to citizenship
or amnesty for illegal residents that
were already here
the cartels were listening most of you
know that
that the cartels infrastructure is
incredibly well developed and
and they are very well funded so
they began getting ready man they were
hoping for
a biden victory and on january the 20th
joe biden was inaugurated as our
president so
that i'm gonna i'm gonna ask
president biden to please pay attention
because i'm talking straight to you now
sir
allow us an audience with you
you have been misled your
the policies that you have signed into
effect
are injuring the american citizens you
serve
and endangering the children of god that
are making this trek
to our southern border under incredibly
dangerous
circumstances allow the
the voice of reason to enter
the white house you took charge of this
country
on january the 20th on the very same day
you gave control of our border
to the cartels
you can fix this thing working with us
if if america is paying attention and i
believe they are your phone's going to
start ringing
i implore you good sir
let us in we can fix this thing
it's beyond the crisis at the border
it's a threat
to our republic and you mr president
have a responsibility to listen to the
citizens that we
serve god bless you one and all
thank you for being here and reporting
this
hi thank you for being here i'm
representative yvette harrell from new
mexico's second congressional district
so the el paso sector
where we just visited today serves the
district that i represent
so i'm grateful for leader mccarthy and
all of these
colleagues of mine coming here to
understand what we're facing
and i don't want to repeat everything
they've said but i do want to let you
know that we have introduced a policy
that is very effective for the border
patrol
and they just told us repeatedly title
42 is helping
but if this president takes that away
then it opens the floodgates even more
so
this title 42 allows our border patrol
agents to
process on the border and expel those
are coming here illegally
because we are under pandemic conditions
and i know there's not one of you in
this crowd that hasn't been impacted by
the covet 19.
maybe know somebody who passed away
somebody who's sick somebody who is
alone in the hospital
somebody who lost a job close to
business we've all been impacted by cove
19.
and for our president to think opening
the southern border to allow those
coming in and you just heard it
that are infected with or have been
exposed to covid
makes no sense at all so the spot in the
curve and all the work we've done as a
country
to get our kids educated open up our
economies and
ensure that we are doing the right thing
to overcome the pandemic
opening the southern border makes no
sense we've just taken three steps
forward
and ten giant steps backwards so thank
you for being here and covering this
it is a humanitarian crisis but it's all
a public
health crisis and americans are just as
much at risk as those making the trek
over
so thank you for covering this today and
with that
my friend representative salazar from
florida
uh thank you very much leader for
inviting us to come to the quarter my
name is maria salazar and i represent
miami probably the ultimate melting pot
where we have thousands and thousands of
hispanic americans
and i'm going to say my remarks in
english and then in spanish
because we the hispanic americans in
this country
we have a problem and we need to be part
of the solution
we need to join forces and send the
message that we cannot allow what's
happening on the border
because it's our our girls when tourists
guatemala and the corral were the ones
who were being raped
it's our girls the ones the children who
are being trafficked
i'm not sure that you know that sex
child sex trafficking is one of the
highest international crimes booming in
this country
so i ask all of you to help me i
i ask my community not only miami but
across the country
the hispanic americans to send the
message to your representatives
that we cannot have this happening of
the border because the overwhelming
majority of the people that are trying
to come in
belong to our group to our ethnic
group we need to stop this we need to
stop being pawns
of the politicians in washington and
pawns of the traffickers who are
trafficking with our children our
families
and our women so it's it's a time
for us to rise up and send the message
something that we haven't done before
loud and clear to your representatives
whether
republicans or democrats it doesn't
matter it's a problem that belongs to
all americans including the hispanic
americans in this country
so i want to invite uh my friend um
carlos jimenez if you want to do this in
spanish so we can send a message
through univision and telemundo sure
okay and uh
thank you to you carlos jimenez uh also
from south florida
yes i want to i want to reiterate what
uh my colleague
maria has said about uh what really
struck me here
we're going to listen a lot to what what
uh what's wrong about
this policy to to america but really
what's wrong about this policy is also
the migrants that are trying to make
this trip here and
the danger that they're being put in i
spoke to a
family and luckily for them they were a
family they were together still
um that told me it took them 22 days to
come from honduras they were
incentivized by the rhetoric
by the change of policy that they they
were actually you know
they it was a pretty harrowing trip many
of them don't make it
uh and so for maria and i and hispanics
across
the nation we need to think about hey
we're putting
our own people's lives at risk because
of this of this uh this policy
and so uh again uh you know i asked the
president reverse the policy
restore some of the uh some of the
agreements that you had
with central american countries and
mexico to make sure that we
dis-incentivize people from coming here
in an illegal fashion being the pawns of
uh traffickers human traffickers they're
the ones that are making all the money
in this they're the ones that are
profiting
from uh from this trafficking is
happening right now and so i'm going to
say a couple of words in spanish
a
thank you it's a privilege to be here at
the border today and i want to thank
leader mccarthy for putting this trip
together to
open the eyes for people like me i
represent the people of the sixth
district of tennessee
a long way from the southern border
today i have to tell the people of the
sixth district and the people of our
great country
that as i look into the eyes of these
young immigrants
of these hopeful families who have been
encouraged to come here
by the misguided perceptions of our
current president
they're coming with the hope to to
achieve the american dream
but unfortunately before they ever have
that chance
to achieve the american dream they're
going to have to experience the biden
nightmare
of making their way across this long and
treacherous track
many of whom will not be successful
and then only to be greeted with the
process
that is not meant to accommodate them
so as i think about the people i
represent back in tennessee
i call upon our president to end this
nightmare
by announcing to the world that the
southern border of the united states is
open
for legal immigration and i call on him
to do now
do that now thank you
good afternoon marionette miller-mice
from iowa it may seem strange to have
someone from iowa
but i'm part of homeland security
emergency preparedness and border
security
and i just want to remind you one of the
things that we learned at the border
today
is that when 120 border patrol officers
are taken from the border to a
processing center
that leaves our border porous and what
did we learn
that there are drug traffickers and
there are individuals on the terror
watch list that are coming across our
border illegally
from yemeni syria iran they're coming
here and they're on the terror watch
list
we also they had a huge apprehension of
fentanyl well interstate 35 goes all the
way up
all the way up to iowa and we have drug
problems all throughout the
i-35 corridor and that continues when we
allow illegal drugs to come in here
trafficking i'm also a former director
of the iowa department of public health
we learned today that there's not
testing that 50 percent of the border
patrol agents have contracted covid19
that there's a mental health strain on
them imagine during the pandemic
having had policies at work and in the
blink of an eye
having policies that are stopped and
your life is further put
at risk and you're imperiled trying to
do your best to help families
and to help unaccompanied children and
then i'm gonna speak to you as a mother
i cannot even imagine dropping off a
one-year-old child
to a smuggler to a trafficker to a
cartel
to hopefully that child make it to some
family member
or ngo in the united states of america
that that child not knowing where they
go
and our border patrol and our hhs
try to do their best to make sure that
they get to where they should be
going to some sponsor but we can't
guarantee that
imagine if that's your child
it's unconscionable that we would put
policies in place
that would damage children and that
would damage families
in addition to damage damaging those in
the united states
those policies need to come to an end
this is crisis and disorder at the
border by executive order thank you very
much
and now i'm going to introduce to you
representative mike mcleod
michael cloud from texas 27th the other
side of texas
thank you for being here thank you
mccarthy for taking us here to see
what we had to see today we are a
compassionate nation
but lawlessness is not compassion
aiding and abetting cartels is not
compassion
putting in policies that allow them to
abuse women on the journey
is not compassion allowing them to grow
and be funded into a destabling force in
these nations that are trying to thrive
and survive and create a thriving
economy for their people
is not compassion the policies that the
bodine administration has put in place
has caused this crisis at the border it
was predictable
it was easy to avoid and it's
unfortunate that we are here again
to talk about this today but we have to
be here
the lives of these people deserve it we
need to be here to tell their story
it's ironic that we are taking people
off the border to help
process and do the paperwork to help
these migrants be eventually released
into the united states so essentially we
have turned the people who've signed up
to protect our border
into the last mile delivery system of
the cartel
migrant human trafficking organization
this is tragic it needs to stop
you know it's a different thing when you
come into a situation as a president
and you inherit a crisis and have to
make tough decisions to change it to
stop it and mitigate it
but what's extremely tragic about the
crisis that we find ourselves in today
is all that biden had to do to avoid it
was nothing
all he had to do was nothing
we can fix this we can secure our border
we can protect the lives of these people
and we can keep this nation strong
and help push back the cartel influence
in our nation
and throughout central and south america
what's so difficult is small common
sense ideas that we didn't have to be
here
midnight january 20th 150 miles of wall
was supposed to be built here
they're at 133 17 miles to go
before you build the wall even on
private land you remove the last border
but as president biden became president
it all stopped
so it's not just people coming across
animals and others
the personal questions we asked
the border agents you look in their eyes
they tell you they see more fentanyl
than they've ever seen
they're more than just a job
these people are mothers and fathers
they say they've never seen so many
unaccompanied children
holding hands and walking up to him with
nobody
in sight they told me of a one-year-old
a three-year-old and a five-year-old
holding their hands
could you ever envision that of your
children
this doesn't have to be this way
we're a land of immigrants we can
continue to have that
what's happening right now is beyond a
crisis
it's a human heartbreak for a president
of the united states to ignore
it not acknowledge it or not do
something to stop and save the lives
the health of this nation the safety and
security
of americans and our border is the job
of the president
he is the one who created this and he is
the one who can fix
it with that let's take some questions
yes sir can you tell us a little bit
more about the people and the terrorist
well when we were up at monument 3 they
talked about it that they were seeing
when they talked about the 100 and 200
people at night
that you saw in their eyes they talked
about they're on the list
john catko here who prosecutes
terrorists and others
it was ahead of homeland on the
republican side
ask them the question what list are you
talking about the terrorist
watch list we asked them which countries
are people coming from
yemen iran sri lanka
that's what's coming across and they're
finding they even talked about chinese
as well
and the problem what they would tell you
is that these cartels because the
highway is right next to it
would rush it with 80 people or more to
have the border patrol go there to try
to overrun it
it's not far to be able to get into
safety or security away from
the border patrol agents they have a
short time frame to catch these
individuals but they're embedded
together
when you overwhelm the unit
but think about the opportunity that
these cartels had now have
we had built a facility larger than we
ever thought we could meet
today made history today they over
capacity
and you know what i asked him well is it
slowing down no it's only growing
exponentially every single day
on the very first day the president said
his priority
let's make 11 million citizens so when
you ask the family
from honduras why was it 22 days
because they just got the message about
a month ago
that they should spark this trek
that's the change that is happening
yes you spoke about the children and how
they're suffering my understanding is
that a lot of these children
have actually been waiting along the
border for the last
maybe year or two even which also is
inhumane
what is your suggestion of what what
should be the solution
what should happen well i think when you
meet on the other side of the border it
was when it was coming to
um asylum that why would you
risk a child going from a country to a
country
if you're going to claim asylum and
you're leaving another country but
passing another one
wouldn't you want that case because when
the cases are heard in america
80 of them don't reach that so why don't
you have that answer back in your own
home country
we had the program pacer that the that
the president pulled that's why we're
seeing more come
i believe in legal immigration to have a
system that works
but there's never a right time to have
illegal immigration
and when you had your own secretary to
simply say
we're not saying don't come just don't
come right now
what happens is just what maria talked
about the human trafficking of these
children
when we blocked those facilities and we
looked in those rooms that were packed
these were children with no parents
these were children that went numbers of
days
who knows what happened to them who
knows who didn't make it
so no don't encourage him to come
now
well that's perfect and don't don't
misconfuse border security with
immigration
they're two separate right now we have a
border that is not secure
right now we know drugs we know
terrorists
we know what's happening to
unaccompanied children coming across
the right way is to have a system that
can work that you don't wait forever
a right way to have a system that i
believe fundamentally even when you're
talking about an education
when somebody's here they get an
engineering degree in others then we
tell them to go away and compete against
us
i'm going to celebrate because every
family's a family of immigrants
april 23rd this year will be the 100th
anniversary of my grandfather
coming from italy and landing on ellis
island he came with his mother
he applied he had somebody who sponsored
him
he went to work his father his mother
this is a system that we have to keep
families together i don't think we
should
put the married brothers and the others
but let's take a system that actually
works
put it on merit have the ability to come
i believe just as republicans when we
were in the majority
we offer two different bills for
immigration reform
the democrats held back every single
vote instead of moving it forward to the
senate
they rather have it for a political ploy
we can solve the immigration problem but
don't confuse a border crisis
with an immigration problem those are
different
thank you very much for coming
oh my god
are you able to do an interview
foreign